see I [ __ ] love k-holes I mean I
don't even know I have cables I mean I
don't even necessarily know what a
k-hole is I just know that I've had a
lot of [ __ ] crazy experiences where
you can't move
we're like time stops I don't know about
that I can't move I remember at one
point like looking at my feet and they
were like so far away
[Music]
I remember uh I remember another time I
was in a hotel room and the the hotel
room started Free Falling like I was
like looked up and I could like see a
shaft there that the whole room was
falling through they're just falling
down yeah it was just like dude I'm
[ __ ] Free Falling in a hotel room it
was Stephen
I mean [ __ ] like that was just like this
is the best night of my life and like as
a sober guy like nothing's more
important to me than being clean and
sober yeah but still that was the best
night of my life
about that he'll be like he shouldn't
have dosed me but like that was fun
we're gonna stage of the night people
like what's up Molly funny goes yeah
yeah do you get triggered at all hearing
people talk about drugs I mean are you
safe in your sobriety I yeah
weed sounds like I'm sober too and like
we the smell of weed I'm like I don't
like being around weed because I like
the smell of it too plus like there's
like uh it's entering my body when I'm
breathing it in like there's kind of
like secondhand High [ __ ] I don't want
to [ __ ] you apart true true you can't if
you're around Coke it ain't gonna get in
you right alcohol drink all the alcohol
you want around me
um but yeah I feel pretty good about it
you just don't ever want to be I would
never want to say I'm safe in my
sobriety or even I feel safe in my
sobriety like because by definition none
of us are safe in our sobriety we gotta
like stay on top of like
but you know what I'm talking about
though right yeah some guys like day to
day guys other people like oh I don't
really think about it I don't think
about actually going to get loaded too
much no I I I'm more triggered on the
sex stuff because like I work a sex
program too like that that's a whole
other ball game where it's like a
not drinking booze like that's minor
like trying to [ __ ] stay within some
guard rails of like sexual sobriety like
that's a little tougher
sexual sobriety yeah somebody's throwing
a nacho yeah and then you're like my
body wants it yeah and then it's like
okay cool what's healthy it's like yeah
you can have some sex and then it's like
well I didn't use it I didn't use a
rubber nice and then you're like [ __ ] oh
yeah I just feel like worried for the
next that's the whole point of ease and
then you're like you gotta then you got
to keep in touch with the girl so as you
until her next period
so you're sure but yeah so it's just
like thing you know that that's more on
the Forefront of my mind than like
drinking a Coors Light who says rubber
what are you born in the [ __ ] 40s why
what do they call it prophylactic no not
even early what are you a nerd rubber
guys
sometimes you know a bang
so sometimes meaning one chick sometimes
or yeah no I've had chicks before but no
no no right you ever want to get married
or no nah never no no married no kids no
kids I got a vasectomy me too dude yeah
it's easy right yeah well not the way I
did it
don't go wrong I have a show tonight if
you want to you have a story about it
yeah that's one of the the Marquee bits
I got one too the vasectomy Olympics
I do want to know what that means yeah
like the the idea was born when I heard
a joke when I was a kid what's uh the
definition of Macho okay a man who jogs
home from his own vasectomy
and I was like well I want to be macho
like uh I'll do way more than [ __ ]
jog so I came up with an idea like to
just do a bunch of hellacious [ __ ]
immediately after getting a vasectomy oh
dude
you're the only one like you
kind of it's called Stevo's hot sauce
for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude